Hello, everybody
My name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Will You Press the Button. Now this dilemma is interesting you gain the ability of mind control,
but the people you control will be aware that you took control of them and will react to what you did to them
while under the effect. So you can control everybody, but your manipulations are laid bare for the people that are
being manipulated. I mean,
the best comment is "That would be fucking hilarious"?
I don't know what you plan to do with people in their mind control, but I don't think it's going to be so hilarious. So
basically you become a super villain, in a way, you control people for your own ends – No! You become like – oh that guy?
What was that guy? The purple guy! The purple man! Purple man!?
Here's purple man. You know, purple man from Zooey Deschanel's
Power Girl? What was it?
I can't remember what the name of it was. The guy, he could control people's minds with a virus, and they would do
anything that he instructed them to do, no matter what it was, and they could not resist.
But they were aware of it, and that was horrible, so I don't think imma do that
I think I'm gonna pass on that one. Whoa-ho-ho
It's 66% of people that think they could use that power responsibly? I don't think that's true.
You have an endless supply of food, but you have to workout four hours of every day for the rest of your life.
I mean, an endless supply of food would solve world hunger – is that not true?
It would it would be better for everybody in the entire world, and heck, I would just get superduper in shape...
Like I would get crazy in shape all for the benefit of the world? I don't see a loss there!
I'm gonna take that! Hell yeah, I would! Hell yeah! Also,
it doesn't say what kind of workout you have to do. It could be working out in my mind.
Ha ha ha ha. You have the
permanently active power to control your luck and the luck of those around you, but in order to control whether it is bad luck or
good luck and the intensity you must be given permission to by a man in a suit who will withhold it to manipulate
you as he sees fit (*trails off into disgust*).
So... I get to make everybody around me either bad or good lucky by the whims of a man in a suit??
Ah! It doesn't say–, it doesn't say a specific man in a suit! It says *a*
man in a suit.
This could be any man in a suit. I could wear a suit. I'm a man.
I've got a suit. I can change– I could– I could do it. I could do it. I could do that.
See, ha ha, I found you. I'll press that button.
I'll just get one of my friends to tie themselves in a suit and give me lots of good luck, right?
Ooh, split down the middle, there.
Alright, become god, but everyone is an atheist and hates you and you cannot change their opinion or make yourself happy. Meh...
I mean...
What does that really matter?
Basically you become Dr. Manhattan, right? In the Watchmen comics like Dr.
Manhattan basically had the powers of a god,
like he could make matter out of an energy and like he could manipulate he was a quantum being and
basically existed outside the realms of our universe except that he was in it, so
you become a god you become a God with whatever powers that are godly
and you can make whatever you want your destiny is outside of it. You can't change their opinions.
They will always hate you, and you can't make them happy
But, you know hey, he's got the powers of a god.
That's not too shabby. I don't know I'll prob– I'll take that. Oh, no people didn't do that. "Kill them"–
"I kill them all". Alright well. Oh no. Okay,
this is funny because I've actually been reading a lot of warhammer 40k books.
And you will become a god-like emperor that rules over all mankind in the year 40k,
but you'll have to stay on a golden throne that requires souls to keep you alive. So for those of you who
don't know, the god emperor of mankind sits atop a golden throne (*goes all regal and crazy*) because he was
betrayed by his son, Horus, during the Horus Heresy and the arcane mechanisms of the golden throne must keep him alive with the daily
sacrifice of a thousand sychars a day blending their energy to the
astronomicon to power it for the betterment of humanity and keep the imperial web way closed
for all eternity! Oh, you know, sorry.  I'll do that.
I'll take up that charge, because who knows what the lord is gonna spill for me later. I don't know, I'll take it.
I'll do it. I'll do it. Give me our–
Put me on that throne make me a god. Actually, that'd probably be terrible. God, I can't imagine... Just sitting in the same chair for
40,000 years. Might as well do let's plays while I'm up there, I suppose. A fridge that contains any food/drink
you want, fully prepared and ready to eat whenever you open the door, but the fridge takes up half of the space
where you live, you still have to pay for the food, and you still gain weight? Well, that's–
Well that's fine by me, if I could have Cracker-Barrel chicken and dumplings anytime I want! And they are too expensive!
I'll b- I'll buy that!
That sounds awesome! And a "half of the space where I live" well, I mean, that's fine.
I don't need that much space. If I have food anytime
I want I could have people over and I can impress them with any delicacy that they could desire. That sounds great.
I want that. Give me that fri– What!? Oh, you crazy people! I guess that means– you could just cook it.
There's– there's this Temmie Armor: "so a normal fridge. You just don't have to cook."
Damn it, you're right. God. Damn it. God damn it. You're right.
You become the Doctor's new companion and travel through space and time, but you will die during an adventure.
So I'd become his new companion and that, and then I generally just be what his companion is and then I would die
for the Doctor Who. I'm gonna go with no,
because that never seems to turn out well no matter which way you slice it. No matter
what happens, like, you'll create an alternate version of yourself that will have to suffer or
you'll be the alternate version of yourself, and then you'll die in a time loop and basically going with the Doctor is
just a horrible, horrible, horrible thing. I will not do that, sir. I will not do that.
You have the abilities of changing into any creature you want– Animorphs!–
but you have to stay that animal for a month every time you change appearance.
I mean, okay, can we go mythical animals? What kind of creatures are we talking about here?
Can I be an alien? Can I be anything? Can I be different versions of people?
I mean, technically humans are an animal. I can just change my face every month. I can stay incognito for the rest of my life.
Doesn't sound so bad. I'll do that. I'll do that.
Hell yeah. Alright, everything will be free just for you, but except for electronic goods which will be more expensive.
I think this guy's got the right idea about it. Sebastian exchanged diamonds and golds and other raw materials for cash.
I mean, technically yeah, that's kind of working around the system. There's something saying that exchanges don't exist
I can get something for free and then sell it later and get anything. I want yeah, that sounds good. There's no downside to that. Easy-peasy.
Oh, no: Live in the world of GTA5 but it is in 8-bit.
Why would I want to do that!? Because luck be have it for me
I wouldn't be one of the main protagonists or antagonists in that game.
You know the type that gets to go to the hospital every time?
No, I'd be one of the regular street people that has people in rocket ships just exploding over the horizon every single morning.
And then they just respawn when the police careen and through my house, and then I die
instantly, and even worse my life is in 8-bit. How is that any better? I don't want that at all. No thank you.
I don't want any part of that.
Let's see. You can end all suffering in the world all oppression and essentially create world peace and save billions of lives
but you must choose– you must "chose" one of the people you're closest to in the world to act as a sacrifice. Well I mean,
one life for the end of all suffering. Like... I don't even need to debate this one.
I don't– You know, I know I'm sacrificing one of my friends, here
but hey, I think that one of my friends would be like "oh yeah, that's– that– that's a good deal. sacrifice me"
I can guarantee you that I would have a friend– and if friend of mine needed me to sacrifice for that outcome?
Oh, hell, yeah, oh hell yeah. Oh
sacrifice me up. Burn me on a pyre. I don't care. Oh, you– Oh, you cowards!
You cowards. You can control a mind, but it's only your mind.
So what? Are you saying like I have the amount of control that I would have over like a sim?
I'll assign myself to a task, and I won't be able to change it because my mind wants my mind to do that?
How does that work for my mind controlling my mind?
You don't know what my mind does! My mind is my mind and my mind alone!
But– but if my mind is controlling my mind does that mean is my mind or my mind telling my mind what to do?
I don't mind if my mind tells me what to do because it's my mind.
I'll press– oh, no. Ow, my brain hurts. Ow.
Alright, you can see through clothes and see anyone naked – I don't know if I want that – but everyone around you,
everyone around can see you naked when you use the power.
Hey...
No downside! Everyone gets the Glory of me naked!
God, why would I want that? Why would I want to be TSA all times?
Why would I want that? I don't think I want that. I don't want,
I don't want. I don't want to see everyone naked. I'd rather not, you know. I will not do that.
Oh really? 51 percent of people are so desperate to see everyone else in the world naked? God,
you don't know what you're asking for there. Ah.
I dunno. I mean, I know it's optional
I know, it's optional you don't have to do it all the time, and there's use for it here and there
but I mean, it's like. I don't need that. I don't need that. I'm good. My life is okay without that.
I'm good.
Ooh.
This is interesting. You can create a universe exactly as you detail it, but in order to create this alternate universe
You must die.
So basically you're creating a universe that you would never ever be a part of. You–
It's not like you die to go into this universe you can create a world that you want with your rules
exactly the way that you want it,
but you'll never enjoy it. So in the end, is there really a point to it? Is the creation of this world
that is basically fiction to you, but is real to the people in it and will really tangibly exist...
Is about worth
dying for? And how would you even have all of the
wherewithal to be able to detail every small nuance about that universe? We don't even know this universe
and we got like a billion people working on that idea.
So how would you be able to detail every absolute detail? It would be a lifetime endeavor
just being able to create this universe, but would it be worth it if
it was made in the first place and would it be worth it it could cost your life?
Think of any fictional universe that you've ever wanted to be a part of. You could make that a reality, and
maybe hope that you'll be born into it after you die, but there's no guarantee for that.
So let me know down in the comments, what you would do. Would you create that universe if it costs you your life?
Let me know down there. So thank you everybody so much for watching. I hope you enjoyed this one
Let me know if you did down the comments below. And as always, I will see you in the next video.
Buh bye.